tout est fait pour les délinquants dans
ce pays tout est fait pour les gens qui
ne travaillent pas que ce soit les aides
que ce soit tout est fait pour ces
gens-là mettent les ailes en question
qui disait qu'elle gagnait 1200 €, elle
travaillait à travailler toute sa vie et
que les gens qui n'ont jamais travaillé
en 920 € de retraite 200 € d'écart entre
les gens qui ont travaillé et qui ne
font rien oui ce pays aide les gens qui
ne travaille pas
je mélange tout mais non je balance pas
tout mélanges tous les aides le chômage
la retraite voilà bravo super
elle a pas travaillé elle a le droit à
rien elle n'a pas le droit à rien la 900
€. mais tu dis oui la 200 mais tu dis
n'importe quoi il y a 200 € d'écart il y
a 200 €. donc à moins travailler elle
fait quoi la dame tu fais quoi
je t'explique calme-toi quelqu'un qui
n'a jamais travaillé elle n'a pas
travaillé elle aura 900 € l'autre aura
1000 2 je dis que l'écart n'est pas si
important et qu'aujourd'hui on ne
récompense pas les gens qui travaillent
pour le et qu'on aide beaucoup les gens
qui